all right listen guys I've been debating
whether or not to do this segment over
the weekend because I don't want to
number one confuse people I don't want
to spread wrong information I don't want
to say something that might get somebody
to take a risky behavior or to put
people at risk of catching coronavirus
but at the same time it wouldn't be
honest for me to keep this information
from you and not to tell you about it
and not to get your thoughts on it
so I am coming to you today not to tell
you that I know what's going on with
lockdowns versus state reopening 'z but
merely to tell you there are clearly
things going on that we don't understand
or at least that I don't understand I
won't speak for others but I'll tell you
that I don't understand let me give you
an example California has been closed
for months
Texas reopened in late April their
curves for cases and deaths are looking
very very similar and again please
understand I'm not saying anything about
lock downs or reopening xym making no
medical or economic claims I am merely
saying something is not making sense and
I don't know what it is and I want to be
super careful because I want to learn
what it is that's going on so let's look
at California in Texas California and
Texas ordered lock downs right around
the same time it was about March 20th
from what we saw
California's lockdown was more strict
than that in Texas and California's
lockdown seemed to be taken more
seriously by people in California
then the Texas lockdown was taken by
people living in Texas the California
lockdown has now been going on two
months
Texas mostly started reopening on April
28th I believe it was we're going to put
the cases up on the screen now there is
no doubt that if you look back to early
May the Texas cases have started to
climb at a modest rate and indeed when
you look at raw numbers Texas has had
some of its higher single-day new case
numbers over the last week or ten days
but the curve is not very different in
Texas than it is in California where you
look at California which has been
unlocked down for two full months now
they also are starting to see some of
their highest case numbers in
last week so I want to be thorough here
I I can imagine
explaining this in a bunch of different
ways so let me give you one example have
the states simply been ramping up
testing and Texas has been ramping up
testing by more than California so the
increased cases are merely a result of
testing more well to some degree that's
true both California and Texas are
testing more now than they were at the
start of the lockdown so to some degree
you could say both California and Texas
are seeing more cases because they are
testing more but how does a state that's
been on a lockdown for two months have
an almost identical curve not raw
numbers but an almost identical curve to
a state that's been open for three weeks
I don't know I don't pretend to
understand now could it be that in Texas
even though they're open people are
still doing a lockdown and in California
even though they're still locked down
more people are ignoring the lockdown I
don't know I don't pretend to know what
if we look at deaths instead of cases
once again it looks similar the curves
are similar California has had way more
deaths in the aggregate California also
has more deaths per capita California
was an early hotspot it has more flights
to Asia more people coming back and
forth from Asia has a bigger population
but when we look at the curve the shape
of the curve we are seeing relatively
high numbers of deaths in California
about a plateau and it's not that
different in Texas Texas had its highest
death numbers about a couple of weeks
ago California had them about four weeks
ago so I don't pretend to know what is
going on but I want to try to think
through some of the ideas I already
mentioned the case numbers are affected
by testing maybe the curves are similar
because testing has ramped up similarly
and it's not reflective of real case
numbers that's a possibility that's a
possibility then you look at deaths
though and the curves look similar
so maybe the deaths haven't yet peaked
in Texas and California's have peaked
are in a slow decline and right now
they're kind of crossing ok that's
possible maybe we'll know that in
another
14 days another argument I saw maybe
Texas is simply lying right like okay I
mean listen I don't put it past them but
in order to hide case and death numbers
while putting out fake testing numbers
or maybe the testing numbers are real
then that would mean that the deaths and
testing and the deaths and cases are out
of proportion it's a coordinated
conspiracy so I don't listen we heard
Florida was at one point hiding cause of
death it's a pretty big conspiracy and I
don't know that Texas is even competent
enough to get away with it is it
possible the heat is a factor well it's
hot in a lot of California as well and
it has been for several months
do the lockdowns not work I mean now we
have information that show lockdowns do
reduce case numbers and deaths in the
aggregate but is it possible that
there's a natural curve that's some kind
of natural timing to the virus that has
a similar trajectory regardless of
policy the lockdown saves people in
numbers but the trajectories end up
being similar I don't know I truly don't
know there was one paper that suggested
that again I mentioned is it possible
that even though California has stricter
lockdown and Texas is reopened
maybe Californians are ignoring it and
some Texans are staying home and it's
sort of evening out is there evidence of
that I don't know I'd I have no idea but
what about maybe I'm cherry-picking by
only looking at California and Texas
okay
let's compare to other states New Jersey
and Florida New Jersey is part of the
big New York hotspot and the big New
York lockdown Florida
famously started reopening stuff weeks
ago the trajectories for cases in
Florida and New Jersey are also very
similar certainly Florida hasn't seen
the same recent decline that New Jersey
had but they both went down for a bit
and they've both popped recently could
it just be testing well maybe but it's
still a similar trajectory looking at
deaths in New Jersey in Florida it's a
very similar curve now to be super clear
the numbers are different the death
numbers in Jersey are way higher they
were
an early hotspot but the curves are
similar with similar timing so you know
I never lie to you I've noticed this I'm
bringing it to you and I want to know
more now the answer could be every place
is doing poorly because of the
disastrous federal response we have no
national contact tracing in place so
even the lockdowns only helped a little
bit I don't know I don't have the answer
but this is the data that I'm seeing I
want to hear from you what do you think
is going on here